seth meyers invited some very special
guests to celebrate american
thanksgiving on thursday's episode of
late night with seth meyers yes and he
was joined by his parents hilary and
larry as well as his brother josh and
with the help of seth's sons ash and
axel they surprise viewers by announcing
a new addition to the family pick up
what
keep an eye out for a couple things one
do you think the dog likes being in this
video
and two keep your eye out if you peel
your eyes very closely there's sort of
an easter egg
that maybe you will find but again watch
very closely
here are the boys in frisbee as turkeys
[Music]
happy days
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is
uh ten weeks ago uh my wife gave birth
to a baby girl
and
i feel like it's only fitting for you to
tell everybody uh what her name is oh my
gosh her name is adelaide addie after my
mother yes which
so i knew
knowing seth and alexi it had to start
with an a it had to be a cool name and i
know what family means to all of them so
i thought i pretty much had it but i
didn't know
and i didn't want to ask yeah and so it
waited you waited until we were on the
vineyard and something was it was a
rainy day and then you said you want to
know the name
and i said i guess so yes and then of
course i burst into tears